[Music]
ha no YouTube chess lovers in my friends
this is Gungan here welcome to my 59th
episode of dirty chest tricks in this
episode I am going to show you a
wonderful high profile trick against
Scandinavian defense from the white
perspective the opening arises after the
following model ephone defy he kept his
defy Queen captures defy and now rather
than playing the move Knight to c3 in my
past I have created the whole wrap Ruta
starting with Knight to have three so if
we haven't check it out I strongly
insist you to go and watch that series
as it will provide you a great recruiter
against all Scandinavian variations
now since white Queen has not been
attacked by far the most aggressive line
from the black perspective is to play
Bishop to g4 pinning down the night and
when we unpin with Bishop to e2 black
will lash out with Knight to c6 as you
can see he really wants to quickly
castle on the Queen side and then become
he'll lose on White King side ok here
the main line continue with d4 however
I'm going to introduce this tricky move
first namely h3 so that if black capture
of a9 then we will obviously recapture
and in that case we will octane the
bishop pair and that will give slight
advantage to the white camp so nope
black is not going to be that
cooperative and obviously enough he is
going to keep that pain with Bishop to
h5
well g4 is not a big threat as black is
intend to castle on the queenside so
that will make White King side bit
weaker so now we have to play in the
center with d4 and there is a small
trick here guys that if black thinks
that he can win a pawn
by following captures Bishop captures f3
Bishop captures f3 and now Queen
captures d4 which at first side Prince
the pawn but it's a big time mistake has
after Bishop capture c6 it is black who
is going to lose his Queen and in fact
the game so that variation is right out
of the equation and that's why the main
line continued with castle on the Queen
side which indeed now pressurize the d4
pawn ok now we are going to strike with
c4 attacking the Queen and again black
has to play the accurate response in one
blitz game one of my lowering opponent
continued here with Queen to e5 which is
again a second important trick in this
line as after Bishop to d2 naturally
enough he continued with Queen to b6
attacking the loose be to pawn but then
I unleash c5 and when my opponent
happily grabbed the B to pawn to his
horror he find out that after Bishop to
c3 his queen is a complete corner so
that is a cute little Queen trap trick
if you open and continue with Queen - if
I check that's why the most popular
choice here for the black is to play
Queen to d6 pressurizing the d4 pawn and
now white responses force White has to
safeguard the d4 pawn and accordingly we
are going to push it and counter-attack
the Black Knight
the first moon night to e Phi
straight away fallen into our tricky
platform as White has this wonderful
sequence starting with night get to see
Phi well black cannot capture over
Bishop as our night is going to be
protected with Queen captures e two so
that means black responses force black
has to capture on ePHI pinning down of a
bishop but in fact after this by force
white is winning now before I move on I
like you to pause this video and find
out the most amazing Noah's Ark trick
from this position are you ready let's
get started the first move is very
obvious G for attacking the bishop
bishop to g6 and now i hope you see this
move
yup effort not only attacking the Queen
but if the Queen goes to the bad square
then F I will literally trap the bishop
the critical response goes as follows
Black has this counter attacking moon
Queen to e4 but here the surprise spring
onto the black table with this nice moon
castle on the Kings side and even though
black has plenty of choices such as
ethics epics and ethics to save his poor
Bishop none of them are working in this
situation let's see how we can trap
black piece in almost all the variation
the first move I want to consider is
ethics which obviously try to cover up
their face quare but unfortunately it is
not enough as after Knight to c3 black
sweetie has
almost running out of the square well
black and through this check but that is
not going to help him as after King 2's
to Blackmun has the only square to run
away namely c2 but after the critical
blue fi which not only trapped this
Bishop but also attacking the Queen so
black response is almost fools he has to
take the Queen first and when white
recapture he can take on fi but the end
of the sequence after G captors fi you
can see finally we have hunt down that
poor bishop
okay what about f6 well more or less
same story as we are going to continue
it Knight to c3 attacking the Queen
Queen has the only square namely c2 and
now you really don't want to play a fire
as Bishop can run away so first we are
going to capture the Queen which invite
black Bishop to come to over territory
and now we are going to close the gate
with fi the best response can goes as
follow g6 trying to free up that trapped
baby but see yourself as after Bishop to
d2 pawn catches fi and rook to c1 again
in again this Bishop has only one square
and now with the simple move G captures
fi not so surprising that Bishop has
been trapped forever
last but not least what happens if he
continued with at six which looks more
natural in this position
however after Knight to c3 we have
pretty much same story yup
Queen to c2 and this time around
White has this very strong reply Queen
to d4
so if allowed then we will capture on a
seven so naturally enough black has to
play the move b6 which allows this
lovely sequence fi and when the bishop
goes to the only square at seven yes
indeed black managed to save his bishop
but still he is going to lose a piece
after Bishop to d3 hahaha so now black
queen doesn't have any escape square so
he has to counter-attack White Queen
with ePHI but after the following
sequence Queen to e4 Bishop to c4 check
King to h1 and Knight to f6 White has
this simple move Bishop kept to c2
Knight captures efore and Bishop to c4
at the end of the whole transaction once
again white emerge with a piece
advantage so this is one of the
wonderful Nowak act trick exists in the
Scandinavian which you definitely want
to consider for your tounament practice
last but not least what happens if here
black continue with Bishop captures have
three well obviously we are going to
recapture and when black played the move
Knight to e5 we have this another tricky
line starting with castle on the Kings
side the point is when black grabbed the
free porn we can continue with Queen to
d4 attacking the knight and after Knight
to be six and the moon a four
yes whities upon down but in return we
get the open C file and avataq already
commenced on the a file and with none of
the black piece has been developed on
the kingside this position usually
favors the white camp that's it guys I
hope you enjoy and learn this wonderful
Nowak our trick in the Scandinavian
defense
remember when you open and play the move
Knight to e5 give him this rude shock
with night cap to defy Queen captures
ePHI and now however black wriggles
after g4 and the moon f4 by force we are
getting the piece just within doping
stage thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care